1221 days ago
who learned of a cluster of cases of
pneumonia of unknown cause in Wuhan
China
on the 30th January 2020 on the advice
of an emergency committee convinced
under the international Health
regulations
I declared a public health emergency of
international concern over the global
outbreak of covid-19 the highest level
of alarm under international law
for more than a year
the pandemic has been on a downward
trend
with population immunity increasing from
vaccination and infection
mortality decreasing and the pressure on
Health Systems easy
this trend has allowed most countries to
return to Life As We Knew It Before
kovid 19.
for the past year
the emergency committee and who have
been analyzing the data carefully and
considering when the time would be right
to lower the level of alarm
yesterday
the emergency committee met for the 15th
time and recommended to me that I
declare an end to the public health
emergency of international concern
I have accepted that advice
it's therefore with great hope that I
declare covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency
however
that does not mean covid-19 is over as a
global Health threat
last week covid-19 claimed life every
three minutes
and that's just this we know about
as we speak thousands of people around
the world are fighting for their lives
in intensive care units
and millions more continue to live with
the debilitating effects of post
covid-19 condition
this virus is here to stay
it's still killing
and it's still changing
the risk remains of a new of new
variance emerging that cause new surges
in cases and does
the worst thing any country could do now
is to use this news as a reason to let
down its God
to dismantle the systems it has built
or to send the message to its people
that covid-19 is nothing to worry about
what this news means is that it's time
for countries to transition from
emergency mode to managing copied 19
alongside other infectious diseases
I emphasize that this is not a snap
decision
it's a decision that has been considered
carefully for some time
plan for and met on the basis of a
careful analysis of the data
if need be
I will not hesitate to convince another
emergency committee should covid-19 once
again put our world in peril
while this emergency committee will now
seize its work
it has sent a clear message that
countries must not seize theirs
on the committee's advice I have decided
to use a provision in the international
Health regulations that has never been
used before
to establish a Review Committee to
develop long-term standing
recommendations for countries on how to
manage covid-19 on an ongoing basis
in addition who this week published the
fourth edition of the global strategic
preparedness and response plan for covet
19.
which outlines critical actions for
countries in five core areas
collaborative surveillance Community
protection safe and scalable care access
to counter measures and emergency
coordination
for more than three years
the experts on the emergency committee
have devoted their time
their experience
and their expertise
not just to advise me on whether
covid-19 continues to represent a global
health emergency but to also advise on
recommendations for countries